While we often talk about puberty’s
effect on the body,
what gets overlooked are the fascinating
changes that happen in the brain.
I’ve been sent here to talk
to you about puberty.
Any questions?
During puberty, your reproductive organs
grow and mature.
Any questions?
This ripening allows you to become
a sexually mature adult.
There are so many other changes
to your body
that puberty can seem almost magical.
I think I'll take it from here.
Puberty, in fact,
begins in the brain.
At some point, usually
between the ages of 9 and 14,
puberty is triggered when a region
known as the hypothalamus
releases waves of a specialized hormone.
As convenient as it would be to go
to sleep a child and wake up an adult,
this maturation is slow,
and puberty lasts as long as 4 to 5 years.
And during this extended process,
the brain undergoes
its own transformation,
thanks to two of puberty’s key players—
estrogen and testosterone.
Produced in the developing
testes and ovaries,
these hormones hitch a ride
to the brain via the bloodstream.
Once there, they interact
with receptors on neurons,
changing the way the individual cells
work and function
by making them more or less excitable,
altering their growth,
or reshaping their connections.
Cumulatively, this can change how
you feel, think, and behave.
For example, hormones remodel
and develop the limbic system,
a collection of brain regions responsible
for emotional behavior.
Research in animal models suggests
that the amygdala undergoes changes
in size and connectivity during puberty.
The amygdala’s function is wide-ranging,
from detecting threats
in your environment,
to helping you recognize emotions
in your friend’s faces.
Its development allows you to better
connect with your peers,
while priming your brain
for learning and discovery.
Likewise, puberty organizes
and restructures the nucleus accumbens
involved in reward and sensation-seeking.
Activity in this dopamine
hub is thought to drive
the pleasurable sensations we feel when
doing rewarding activities,
like spending time with friends
or having new experiences.
Several studies have found
that as hormone levels increase
through puberty,
so does the response
of the nucleus accumbens.
As a result, exploration and social
engagement may feel
that much more important
during adolescence.
As these emotion and reward
centers rapidly develop,
their connections with higher cortical
brain regions tend to do so
on an extended timeline.
These cortical regions, which help impose
emotional regulation and impulse control,
continue to grow well past puberty,
into your 20s.
While teens are often unfairly stereotyped
as rash or impulsive,
research reveals a more complex story.
Teens are just as capable as adults
of making thoughtful decisions
when given the time and space.
It’s only during high stress
or in the heat of the moment
that teens may find it more
difficult to manage emotions.
Further, this lengthy cortical development
allows adolescent brains
to remain adaptable as they learn
and grow in new situations,
form their identities, and build
the skill sets needed for adulthood.
For all we know about the effects
of puberty on the brain,
there remain many unanswered questions.
What sets off the initial puberty
signal in the brain?
Why is the average onset
of puberty shifting earlier?
And, while hormones may seem powerful,
they may not be the full story.
Experiences you have during adolescence
may be just as influential
as hormones in shaping and maturing
the developing brain.
So while all these physical and mental
changes can make you feel
as if puberty is in control,
you have more power than you think.
The everyday choices you make,
from learning new skills, to being
a good friend, to setting boundaries,
ultimately steer the path
of who you are and will become.
Any questions?